and now for a breath of fresh air a
young lady who in one of her very first
pictures cactus flower won an Academy
Award we've made two movies together
since then
and it's been pretty much all downhill
for her straight down fortunately she's
learned to make good living without me
ladies and gentlemen please welcome my
favorite leading lady Goldie Hawn
a long walk in this dress anyway this is
so much fun to be up here together
no we look great together we shut up now
listen nobody except the president of
the Academy Bob why's he said there were
a billion people watching us tonight
that's a lot of people see game over
you can't pull this a lot of people when
you think about how many people there
are in the world how many people are
they in the world houses no come on
champ right you're right you're right
this is a big moment for all of us you
want an Academy Award I think this
opportunity for everybody in the world
billions of people millions to hear what
it was like what went through your mind
at the moment your name was mentioned
nothing
the experience was numbing no I was
asleep where were you I was in London
and I was making a movie there I was
making as a girl in my soup and I don't
know why I was new and and I've been
nominated and I didn't expect to win and
I was working on a movie so I decided to
go to sleep I I really I forgot
completely how could you sleep where you
extremely excited where he'll overwhelm
well I didn't know like I said before
you know I didn't know that boy didn't
tell them what it felt like well it felt
like you know well at 5:00 in the
morning I got this phone call and
there's the buzzer
anyway anyway it's good to have you out
here thanks for coming by skidding
jelica pantyhose Vindi llegará
I don't see what
okay-y what's that
hello earthlings I'm Leonard Nimoy and
I'm William Shatner and we have
materialized to the magic of
special-effects they're so good at magic
I wish they could conjure up a couple of
awards for us don't be greedy it's
better to give the receipt your
attention no I don't think I think about
the no I'd rather have an awesome
service let's get on with it it's an
important award visual effects visual
effects in a motion picture Kent husky
average character and tell a story and
the men who create these things don't
exist that don't exist are stars in
their own right and their own galaxy the
nominees for visual effects are aha
aliens robert Skotak Stan Winston John
Richardson and Suzanne Benson Little
Shop of Horrors reviled Conway bran
Ferren
working together
there's our guys to the other side which
Oh Gary Waller and
speaking for us all including Dennis
gotek and Brian Johnson and the entire
effects team we'd like to thank the
members of Motion Picture Academy
our producer Gale Anne Hurd and most of
all the creative genius responsible for
it all Jim Cameron thank you Jim we
would also like to thank our respective
crews who went to make up the
anglo-american team because they did all
the work
thank you fellas Thank You Academy great
recognition thank you thank you so much
you